[Music]
Welcome to Bible Answers Live, where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions.
Let's face it, it's not always easy to
understand everything you read in the
Bible. With 66 books and more than
700,000 words, the Bible can generate a
lot of questions. If you'd like answers
to your Bible questions, you've come to
the right place. Now, here's your host,
Pastor Doug Bachelor, president and
speaker of Amazing Facts.
Hello, friends. Would you like to hear
an amazing fact? Hidden among the
tropical beaches in the Gulf of Mexico
and the Caribbean, you can find a
harmless looking tree with a sweet
smelling fruit and it looks like crab
apples. But this is one apple in
paradise you do not want to eat. In
fact, even a single bite of the luscious
looking fruit can cause hours of agony
and potentially even death. According to
the Guinness World Records, the
machineal tree is in fact the most
dangerous tree in the world. When eaten,
the fruit is reportedly to be pleasantly
sweet at first with a subsequent strange
peppery feeling. Gradually, this
progresses to a burning sensation and
tightness in the throat followed by
terrible gastronomical problems.
Symptoms continue to worsen until the
patient can barely swallow solid food
because of the excruciating pain in the
swelling in the throat. In fact, every
part of the tree is toxic. Macanal trees
are also so poisonous that even standing
under one of them in the rain can cause
your skin to blister and the smoke from
burning any part of the tree can
seriously injure the eyes. Spanish
explorer Juan Pon DeLeon died after
being struck by an arrow that had been
poisoned with a mechal sap. We can
understand why Columbus called them
death apples and the Spanish call it
arbold de la lam muerte which literally
means tree of death. You know the Bible
also speaks about a tree of death and a
tree of life. Stay with us friends.
We're going to learn more as Amazing
Facts brings you this edition of Bible
Answers Live.
You're listening to Bible Answers Live.
Honest answers to your Bible questions.
Our phone lines are now open. If you
have a Bible related question, call us
at 1-800 God says. That's 1-8004637297.
Now, let's join our host, Pastor Doug
Bachelor.
Welcome, listening friends. We're so
thankful that you've tuned in to Bible
Answers Live. And if you're new to the
program, this is a live international
interactive Bible study. And if you have
a Bible question, you can simply call
that toll-free number with your
question. We've got Wow, all the lines
are open. So tonight's a good time to
give us a call. 800 God says with your
Bible question. That's 8004637297.
And as always, we're going to start the
program with prayer. Loving Lord, we
just want to thank you again for the
privilege of being able to get together
with our friends around the country and
other parts of the world and study your
word. I pray Lord that uh you will take
charge of this program the nature of the
questions that come in and especially
that the answers will be in harmony with
your sacred word. We thank you and we
pray this in Jesus name. Amen. You know
friends I trust that you found that
interesting a little amazing fact about
the Mcalil tree better known as a tree
of death. You know, I've been on a
number of Caribbean islands, and I think
I remember years ago having someone
point this out to me and saying, "Don't
go near that tree. Don't touch the
tree." And they promise that terrible
things could happen. But and you look at
pictures and they do look like little
green or yellowish crab apples. And the
tree looks harmless enough, but it is
full of very terrible toxins. You know,
the Bible talks about a tree of death.
And you can read about this in the first
book. The second chapter, it also talks
about a tree of life there in the garden
of Eden. Genesis chapter 2, the tree of
life was also in the midst of the
garden, and the tree of the knowledge of
good and evil. And if you read in verse
16, it says, "And the Lord commanded the
man, saying, of every tree in the
garden, you may freely eat, but of the
tree of the knowledge of good and evil,
you shall not eat it, for in the day
that you eat it, you will surely die."
And you know, a lot of people have heard
that um Eve ate the forbidden apple.
Well, the Bible doesn't ever say they
were apples. It's called the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil. There was a
test that was given to man in the
beginning to be faithful and to obey
this and to trust the Lord and the
serpent got up in the tree and and he
tempted the woman and subsequently to
man to disobey. And all the trouble and
misery we have in this world today is
because they doubted the word. You know,
Eve saw that serpent up in the tree and
I couldn't help but uh mention that with
a machineal tree that we talked about,
that poison tree in the Caribbean,
there's it's toxic for birds and
animals, but there is a black spined
iguana that can live in the tree and eat
the fruit and it seems to be immune.
It's kind of like the serpent in the
forbidden tree. Well, that forbidden
tree where man fell into temptation is a
symbol of temptation. And temptation
will lead to death if we continue to
give in. You can read in James 1:14 and
15. But every man is tempted when he's
drawn away of his own lusts and enticed.
Then when lust has conceived, it brings
forth sin. And sin when it is finished,
it brings forth death. And the devil
tempts us in things that we may think
are innocent and harmless at first. But
step by step, the progression leads away
from God. And the final verdict is
death. You know, uh, if you've been
struggling with some area in your life,
uh, where you're being tempted and you'd
like to know how you can get the victory
over that, we have a special book we'd
like to offer to you for free. It's
called Tips for Resisting Temptation. I
think in the book, we've got about a
dozen tips that you'll find very
helpful. And there's scriptures for each
one of them in ways that you can gain
the victory over certain besetting sins
or habits and patterns that you would
like to, you know, maybe they've chained
you for years and they've controlled
your life and you say, "How can I be
free from this habit?" The Bible can
tell you how to be free and to it's got
the antidote for that tree of death. And
if you'd like your free book, simply
call the resource line. This is another
phone number. It's 8008356747.
There's also chaplain standing by at
that number. If you've got a prayer
request and you want someone to talk to,
that's 800 835-6747.
If you want to call in with your Bible
questions, lines are open. 800 God says
for your questions. 8004637297.
Once again, I'm Pastor Doug Bachelor.
Pastor Jean Ross is off for the night
and we're getting ready to go to New
York. Take our first call from James.
James, we'd like to welcome you to your
uh to the program. Thank you for your
call. Thank you for being there for us.
How can we help you tonight? Uh the book
of Matthew uh chapter 6 verse 15 says,
"If you forgive not men their
trespasses, neither will your father
forgive your trespasses."
Which means we have a penalty if we
don't forgive others. Does that is that
penalty the loss of our salvation or is
it perhaps at the judgment seat of
Christ uh we don't get as much reward?
Well, before I give you a direct answer,
there is a similar passage to this that
you find in Matthew 18. Jesus tells a
parable about a servant and the king
brought this servant in and he had done
some accounting and this servant had
wasted well I think it's 10,000 talents.
A talent is a weight. He had wasted
millions of dollars of the king's money.
And the king said, "All right, then sell
him to be a slave. Sell his family. Sell
his possessions." The man fell down
before the king and he begged and
pleaded and said, "Have mercy and I'll
pay it all back." And the king was moved
with a compassion. He said, "All right,
I'm going to forgive you." But that same
servant went out and found another
servant that owed him $40. And he took
him by the throat and said, "Pay me what
you owe." And the servant said, "Be
patient. I'll pay you back." and he
would not be patient, but threw him in
prison to be tortured and to suffer for
his $42. Well, when the king found out
that this servant who had just been
forgiven millions was so vindictive with
another servant that had only offended
with $40, he said, "You wicked servant,
I forgave you that tremendous debt
because you asked me. Couldn't you have
also had mercy on your fellow servant as
I had pity on you?" and he then
delivered him to prison to be tormented
for his sin. So this man originally was
forgiven, but because he would not pass
on the forgiveness, he lost it. Now
Jesus closes that parable again. This is
Matthew 18. He said, "So likewise will
my heavenly father do unto you if you
each of you does not from your heart
forgive every man his brother their
trespasses."
And so yes, it is true that you know
obviously if we are unforgiven for our
sin, we are then going to pay the
penalty for our sin which is death. Uh
so there's no in between where we're
unforgiven and still in heaven. So
eternal death. Yeah. Well, you know the
penalties of the lost are cast into the
lake of fire. But is it not true that
the scriptures tell us if we are
repentant of our sins and we believe in
Christ, there's no way we can lose our
salvation. One of the sins we're to
repent of is unforgiveness.
So, isn't that right? Um, well, I I
could be a true believer and I I could
repent of all my sins other than this
one I just committed. Now, James, are
you having problems forgiving someone?
No, no, no. This is academic. Okay. I
did ask you at a um at a congregation
and the uh the religious leader didn't
quite know how to answer it. So, that
that's why I was calling you. Well, I
believe that everybody that is truly
saved is going to have the spirit of
Christ. And if you've got the spirit of
Christ, obviously the spirit of Christ
involves forgiveness. And it's not
always easy. And it doesn't mean that
you need to let people continue to walk
over you. But you let it go and you
forgive them. You you shouldn't be going
through life being angry and judgmental
because you just wear out your life
doing that. It doesn't help them. It
doesn't hurt them. It just hurts you.
And the Lord says that he'll forgive us
first. The first forgiveness came from
the king. Then the king wanted that
fellow servant to pass it on. And so um
you know this is the this is a
principle. So I would say yes, if a
person is being unforgiving
that that can jeopardize their
salvation. Jesus said, "If you do not
forgive every man your trespasses, your
heavenly father will not forgive you."
It's it's just very clear. And if you're
not forgiven, you're lost. So I know
that's uh tough and we all struggle with
that, but it is the scripture and that's
why we need to pray for the spirit of
Christ to help us forgive. Hey, thank
you for your question, James. And uh
that does open another line. If you've
got a question, give us a call. And uh
that's 800 Godd says. We're going to
talk to Patricia in Is that Orlando,
Florida?
Yes. Hi, Patricia. Hey, you know, I'm
going to be in Orlando in what about
three weeks doing a series. Oh my gosh,
that's good. Pastor Doug, this is I was
just telling the person who answered the
phone, this is my first time calling in
because I heard you on the radio station
and I had a question because I'm reading
through the New Testament. Well, good.
Listen, I hope that uh you go to the
Amazing Facts website. you'll hear about
I'm going to be there doing a program
for about uh 8 days. It's called
Prophecy Encounter. I'll be going
through the primary prophecies in the
Bible here in Orlando. Tell all your
friends and enemies and invite them and
you'll find the information there just
at the Amazing Facts website. So, what's
your question tonight, Patricia? Okay,
so mine is a little um it doesn't come
like I guess directly directly from the
Bible, but it is a Bible related
question. A lot of the times in um
society we'll talk about if somebody
changes their name to something else
then they're you know that could be like
a demonic spirit because they're sort of
you know being another person. But you
know God changed the name of some of the
disciples in the Bible. So my question
is what is the difference between I
guess like God changing your name versus
and you you you're going by a different
name versus I guess you changing your
name and going by something different in
the world. Well, that's a good question.
And there's a lot of practical reasons a
person might want to change their name.
And it doesn't mean that you're, you
know, there's anything diabolical
connected with it. If a person's into
Satan worship and they change their name
to Nero, you know, you probably need to
worry a little bit. Oh, but you know,
some people I know friends that they
just have had names that were very
difficult for others to spell or to
pronounce and they said, you know, this
is just becoming a chore. and they'll
either simplify their name or they'll um
you know simplify their spelling. Of
course, every time someone gets married,
at least in the old world, uh a girl
would take the guy's name. It's not I
guess it's you know the independence is
changing that a little bit, but um yeah,
so there's nothing wrong with that. God
did change the names. Usually that was
significant of something spiritual. God
changed Abraham's Abram's name to
Abraham and he changed Jacob's name to
Israel.
and Simon's name. Jesus called him
Peter. And so you've got, you know, a
number in the Bible that had their names
changed and it was a good thing. Okay?
And you'll even find in the Bible where
some of the individuals had um uh you
know, a couple different names they went
by. You know, when you go through the
kings, sometimes one of the kings was
called Aariah, the other place he's
called Isaiah. And you know, and we even
do that in our culture. You know, people
have nicknames and hey, you know, I do
have a book. I'll offer you a free copy
and it talks about names. It's called
The Name of God and it's got some very
interesting, even some funny things
about names that are in the book, but
it's called The Name of God. People have
questions about all the different names
for God in the Bible. Patricia, if you
call the resource line, 8008356747,
we'll send you a free copy of the name
of God. Thank you very much for your
call. And with that, we're going to talk
next to Monica calling from Long Island,
New York. Monica, you're on the air. Oh,
yes. Um, hello, Dr. Joe. Nice to hear
from you. I I thought you off were off
the air, but I actually have two brief
quick questions. I believe their answers
might be in Revelation, but I'm not sure
where the first one is. I appreciate the
anticip.
Get real close to your phone because I'm
having a hard time hearing you. I
appreciate all the antiquity of the
history of the Bible and all the
patriarchs of nature. However, I believe
we are in the last days. And if we are
in such, aren't we supposed to be
hearing the ministers and the pastors
teaching the teachings of Christ in the
last days? Number one, and number two,
in the book of Revelations, when we
supposed to honor Christ, is his name
Christ or is his name in the last days
the word of God? if you can just
pinpoint the direction to find the
answers to those two questions. All
right. Well, I'll do my best. I
appreciate your question. Uh yes, by all
means, we should be uh uh teaching the
teachings of Christ. Now, when you teach
the Bible, uh we believe that you are
teaching the teachings of Christ because
Jesus word, the Bible is the word of
God. and and the word of God is not just
the red letters in your Bible, but
Christ is the one who inspired with the
Holy Spirit all the teachings in the
Bible. So when Moses is speaking in the
Old Testament, you're reading his word.
You're reading the teachings of Christ.
Um so Jesus did not suddenly appear 4 BC
and you know live his life and teach and
his teachings do not contradict the Old
Testament. Christ said, "If you believe
Moses, you'd believe me because he spoke
of me. If you believed Abraham, you
believe me. And so, um, and then your
second question was, should we call
Jesus Christ or should we call him the
word of God? Well, you know, the word
Christ actually means anointed. Uh, in
Hebrew, you've got the word Messiah,
which means the anointed. And in Greek,
you've got Christos. That's why when
they they splatter a ship with champagne
and they christen it, uh, it means to
anoint something really. So Christ is
the anointed. And so when we call Jesus
the Christ, we're calling him the
anointed, the chosen, the one who is
filled with the spirit of God. Um his
earthly name that the angel gave was
Jesus, which means savior. It's actually
Yeshua, which means Joshua, same name.
And um so there's many names, you know,
you can call him the word of God. You
can call him the bread. He said, "I am
the good shepherd. I am the door. I am
the living water." But you know,
typically we pronounce it with a Greek
pronunciation. You know, you would also
probably appreciate that u uh book that
we offered earlier that's called um the
name of God. And if you want a free copy
of that, 800 8356747
800 835-6747.
We'll send you a free copy. That does
open another line. If you have a Bible
question, give us a call 800 God says
for your questions. This is the number
8004637297.
Appreciate your call. Going to talk next
with Mel calling from Jersey City, New
Jersey. Welcome, Mel. You're on the air
with Bible Answers Live. Praise the
Lord, pastor. Uh I did call your screen.
I had two particular things. One is Mark
7 in chapter 11 and the other one was
the word glory that we read a lot in the
Bible. All right. Now you said the first
question was is the question that was
asking in Mark Mark what chapter? Mark
chapter 11 verse
Markap 7 verse 11. Okay.
Co. Yeah. Uh Coban. Corban. Yeah. It's
Corban. Uh what that he said it is that
you say is a gift. Yeah. Let let me tell
you what was going on. Uh Jesus is
talking to the scribes and Pharisees. He
says all too well you reject the
commandment of God and keep a tradition.
One of the traditions that the Jewish
religious leaders had developed was they
could say that when they die, all of
their property goes to the temple. They
they would basically will their property
to the temple, but while they were
alive, they could use it, but they
couldn't give it to anyone, including
their mother and father. Well, you're
supposed to take care of your mother and
father in their old age. They had no
social security in Bible days. And so
Jesus said, "You're hypocrites. You
disregard the commandment that says,
"Honor your father and mother. You
pronounce Corbin over your property
saying everything I have is a gift to
God. I can't help you mom and dad
because it now belongs to God. But you
could live off it. And it was basically
a loophole that the priest created to
get money from people so they wouldn't
have to take care of their parents in
their old age. Jesus said this tradition
is hypocrisy. So Corbin was the name of
that declaration that they would
pronounce. You know, we get things like
we call annuities and different there's
different names for a legal arrangement
and Corbin was that arrangement. And
your next question was about Glory, you
said. Yes. I promised these call
stringer was I had two which is glory
and she she said to grab one and we did
that just a minute. But Glory is my
other one. We hear that so much in the
uh now I'm I'm thinking um 89 Psalms
chapter 44.
All right, let me go there real quick.
Are you wondering what the word glory
means? Yeah, you hear someone glory,
glory, hallelujah.
So what what are they meaning? What is
that word glory mean? Well, the word
glory means the splendor, the majesty,
the brilliance, the the awesomeness of
God. You're talking about the greatness
of God. So when when you praise the
attributes of God, you are glorifying
him. But the word glory can also mean
just the the brightness and the light
and the splendor and the beauty. And so
um uh that you know that's what it's
talking about there in these psalms. And
uh anyway, hey, I hope that helps a
little bit and we appreciate your
question, Mel. And uh with that, we're
going to go and talk to Kenny who's
calling from Northern California. Kenny,
welcome to the program. You're on the
air with Bible Answers Live. Uh good
evening. Um I I always questioned why
wasn't Ananas's
uh the wife of Ananas.
back. Why wasn't she informed of of her
husband's death? And did they have a
different system there? Because I know
when my dad died, you know, the the
officials got involved and the and and
we we let all the family know and and
they had a chance to get here and say
good say goodbye, but it doesn't it
something doesn't add up there. Well,
yeah. In this you find this story in
Acts chapter 5, and there's these two
two people. the Holy Spirit had been
poured on the church and everybody's
being very generous and very honest and
this husband and wife said, "Look, we're
going to make a big donation to the
church and they said, "Whatever, you
know, we'll sell our property and we'll
commit the proceeds from that." But
after they sold it, they said, "Well,
you know, maybe we did better than we
thought. We ought to keep more of it.
We'll tell the disciples we're giving
all of it, but let's really keep some
for ourselves." So, they conspired
basically to lie. Yeah. They lied to the
Holy Spirit. Yeah. Yeah. And so when
that was Peter saying and they were
convicted not to do it but they did it
anyway. And so when when ananas first I
I but was there some different kind of
laws that those days or something
because I know we we know the uh the
county officials and everybody gets
involved with with the with somebody
dies. Yeah. It didn't seem fair to his
wife that they that they just go take
and bury him without letting them know
letting her know that he died. Yeah.
They did have different laws back then.
They couldn't say goodbye. I know they
did have different laws back then and we
don't know how much time passed between
when uh he died and they wrapped him up.
That might be a time factor. I never
thought of that. So um and they didn't
have telephones and you know maybe they
didn't know how to contact her. There's
probably more to the story but uh I have
been in countries where people died
right there on the side of the road and
as you know they just had county
officials kind of wrap them up, take
them off and bury them. They didn't go
looking for family. They didn't make
announcements. They just said, "There's
a dead person. They buried him." And
that's very sad with the poor. Cheap
then, isn't it? Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Well,
thanks. I I I still not completely
satisfied with the answer. All right.
Well, I wish it it says what it says
there. You know, first Ananas came, he
died, they wrapped him up, took him out,
and buried him. And soon later, she came
and she lied to the Holy Spirit. Peter
gave her a chance to uh straighten out
the story, but she continued with the
the roose. Anyway, appreciate your call,
Kenny. And with that, we're going to be
talking next to Derek, who's calling
from um Minneapolis, Minnesota. Derek,
you're on the air with Bible Answers
Live. Hi, Pastor Doug. Hi. I I have a
question about Matthew 5:28.
Be ye be perfect as your heavenly father
is perfect. Mhm. My question is I tend
to it's almost like an OCD thing and
I've heard you mention it before where
you know when you became a Christian you
kind of felt oh I'm speeding you know
that's you know a sin or you mentioned
that in one of your sermons. I don't
know if you remember it but that's kind
of how I am when I am trying to live
like a Christian life. I I almost get
obsessive about things like, oh, like,
you know, is this a sin listening to
this commercial because it has a secular
song in it? Is this a sin because, you
know, I'm hanging out with a friend that
uses God's name in vain. And I just
almost feel like you have to become a
monk to be perfect, you know? And like
it's, you know, it's a sin. It makes you
cringe because you know it's not right.
But it's almost like this whole world
we're marinated in sinfulness and it's
just the way the culture is. I mean, you
can't even turn on a television without,
you know, sinful things coming on. How
what recommendation do you have for me?
How do you deal with it as a pastor?
Because I know there's tons of pressure
on you, you know, how how do you do it
where you don't just give up and say,
"I'm, you know, this is impossible to be
perfect. You know, I don't know how to
do it." Well, first of all, God will
never ask us to do something without
giving us the power to do it. I I think
first of all, we we need to know what
does Jesus mean there in Matthew 5:48
when he says, "Therefore, you'll be
perfect even as your father in heaven is
perfect." That same verse that you find
in Ephesians, I'm sorry, in Luke, he
says, "Be therefore merciful, even as
your father in heaven is merciful."
So what he's saying here in Matthew
chapter 5, he said you shall love your
neighbor. And Jesus said even love your
enemies. So the kind of love, the kind
of perfection he's especially
emphasizing here is perfect love. That's
why Luke says be therefore merciful even
as your father in heaven is person is
merciful. Um but any commandment that
God asks us to obey, he will give us the
power to obey. Um, don't become
discouraged. It is true. We are in a
world I like the word you use,
marinated. It is just saturated with
sin. And every Christian feels a little
bit of um
struggle and joy. You know, there's joy
of knowing that Jesus is with us and
that he's promise to forgive us. You
will find being holy in a sinful world
is an ongoing challenge. Don't give up.
And the Lord stays with you. And you
know, he wants us to love what's good.
And it's not wrong to, you don't want to
obsess, but you also should be
evaluating everything based on the word
of God and say, "Well, you know, um, how
shall I do this?" He doesn't want you to
go live in a monastery because obviously
you haven't you can't let your light
shine like that. He told the disciples
to go into all the world and teach all
nations. That's, you know, he said, "I
want you to go in. I want you to
influence others. You are salt and you
are light to have a good influence." But
at the same time while we are in the
world he does not want the world in us.
So he's calling us to be holy. Now there
is a book that um you know whenever we
announce the title of this book I think
it rattles people a little bit but it
really is a good book. It's encouraging.
It's called Is it possible to live
without sinning? And it creates a good
balance for people to understand what is
the Lord talking about when he tells us
to be holy. We'll send you a free copy
of that Derek. Just call 800835-6747.
800 8356747.
Tell them you're listening to Bible
Answers Live. We're promising you a free
copy of the book uh is it possible to
live without sinning? And we'll send
that to you. We do have some lines open.
We'll be back in just a few moments.
Friend, if you have a Bible question,
just give us a call. The number again to
the studio with your question is
8004637297.
and uh stand by.
Stay tuned. Bible Answers Live will
return in a moment.
[Music]
Stay tuned. Bible Answers Live will
return in a moment.
Life's a curious thing. I mean, just
when things seem under control, wham!
You're hit with something new. Your
marriage is good. Suddenly, it's on the
brink of divorce.
The job's great. And then it's gone, and
so is your life savings.
You feel healthy. Then your doctor gives
the bad news. What's coming next? You
could look to the stars, but they don't
have the answers.
But this does. The Prophecy Study Bible
by Amazing Facts. This Bible's special.
It's 27 personal study guides lead you
on a life-changing journey through God's
word. To discover real answers to life's
questions, from health and relationships
to family and the future. The hope's in
here.
Get your Amazing Facts Prophecy Study
Bible today by calling 800538-7275
or visit afookbookstore.com.
Can't get enough Amazing Facts Bible
study? You don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truthfilled
programming. Visit the Amazing Facts
Media Library at aftv.org.
At aftv.org, ORG. You can enjoy video
and audio presentations as well as
printed material all free of charge 24
hours a day, 7 days a week, right from
your computer or mobile device. Visit
aftv.org.
[Music]
Every Bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life.
So, what are you waiting for? Get the
answers you need for a fuller, richer,
more confident life. You're listening to
Bible Answers Live.
This broadcast is a previously recorded
episode. If you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air,
please call us next Sunday between 7:00
p.m. and 8:00 p.m. Pacific time. To
receive any of the Bible resources
mentioned in this evening's program,
call 8008356747.
Once again, that's 8008356747.
Now, let's join Pastor Doug Bachelor for
more Bible Answers Live.
[Music]
Welcome back listening friends. If you
tuned in along the way, this is Bible
Answers Live. We are live. And if you
have a Bible question, once again, the
number 800 God says. I'm Doug Bachelor.
Pastor Jean Ross. He's actually in
Orlando, Florida getting ready for a
series that we're going to be doing
there. And it starts on February 17.
It's called Prophecy Encounter. And
we'll be going through the 25th of
February. And uh once again, it's called
Prophecy Encounter. If you just type in
prophecycounter.com,
you'll find out a lot more information
about that series. It'll be streaming on
Amazing Facts TV, 3ABN, Facebook, Roku,
and more. And with that, we're going to
go back to the phones and talk to
Teresa, who's been waiting patiently,
calling from Madison. Is that Madison,
Alabama?
Yes. Okay. And your question tonight,
Teresa? Um, and uh I'm coming out of the
uh King James version. Uhhuh. Uh John
16:33 it says um these things I have
spoken unto you that me might have
peace. Why is it saying might and some
translations have may Why is that? And I
just kind Yeah. The Lord is the Lord is
saying there that he wants us to have
peace. It is our choice. And so he's not
commanding I've spoken this and whamo
you're going to have peace. We by faith
can we may have peace if we accept it.
And so he's saying that we have the
option to receive it. That's all the
word may means there. It doesn't mean
that I'm not sure if I'm going to give
it to you or not. He's saying, you know,
I've made a promise. You may have peace.
And that's what the word might means.
You might have peace. That's a little
more of the old English. But um Oh, and
so it just means if we believe it and if
we follow the criteria that he gives us
there in John chapter 15, he's promised
peace to us. A peace that passes
understanding.
Okay. Yeah. Thank you. Okay. And I hope
you have that wondering. Yeah. God wants
you to have that. All right. Thank you,
Teresa. Appreciate your call. All right.
We're going to talk next to William
who's calling from Arizona. William,
you're on the air with Bible Answers
Live. Uh thank you. Uh, pastor, um,
first of all, I really enjoy your
program and, uh, because of you and a
few other pastors, I've come to know
that Saturday is the Lord's day and, uh,
according to the commandment and he
created it. And so, u, I grew up, uh,
like many Christians, uh, in believing
that the Lord's day is is Sunday. My
question is uh
that we have Bible studies and coming
from Sunday uh believing Sunday is the
Sabbath day. Uh now believing and
knowing that the Sabbath is the seventh
day. We have Bible studies and um we
have quite a few people that believe how
I used to believe about the uh the
Lord's day and they seem to have
scripture that's it appears to be some
strong scripture. There's some scripture
that on the first day of the week in
Acts that they share, but the main one
that bothers me a little bit is in uh
and I use uh both King James uh and
American Standard and both say that uh
chapter 28 in the end of the Sabbath and
I think in American senators is now late
on the Sabbath uh Mary Vanor came to the
grave site to the supplr and uh I
believe that's the earliest account of
the four gospels of the resurrection of
our Lord because it says that God says
that um there was a great earthquake an
angel came down rolled back the stone
and when they were talking uh or went to
the grave site they came to the angel
and the angel says for I know you seek
Jesus for he has already risen and that
go quickly and tell the disciples that
he's in Galilee. So if we if we believe
that it was the end of the Sabbath, not
on Easter Sunday, that the Lord was
resurrected and I and I believe that,
but they it's hard for them because they
have other Bibles that say, well, uh on
Sunday and and so on, but you know, I
really believe in in
Yeah, I have no problem believing that
um Jesus rose on the first day of the
week, which is Sunday. I think most
Christians know that. It simply says
You see the reason it's mentions after
the Sabbath if you read in Luke when
they laid his body in the grave the
everybody in Jerusalem it was a Passover
weekend uh were all very conscious that
the Passover and the Sabbath were coming
and they wanted to break the bones of
the people on the cross to speed up the
death to take their bodies down so they
wouldn't have these bodies hanging up
there through the Sabbath because they
weren't going to do it then. And the
women came back Sunday to finish
inbalming his body because they didn't
finish before sundown on Sabbath. And
they weren't going to do it on Sabbath.
So all the records here are simply
saying that they were waiting for the
Sabbath to be over to resume their work
of inbalming his body. There's nothing
in this that is telling us that one day
is uh a new day became holy.
Well, pastor, I um I have two points
that I I wanted to uh bring up and and
Okay, we got to do it quick because we
have several people standing by. Oh,
okay. Uh one is that the four gospels
never did say what day that Jesus
resurrected. They say that uh they some
say Sunday, some say uh the Sabbath. And
the point is sometime prior to that
event Jesus was resurrected. Number two
is he promis Jesus promises as sure as
Jonah was the belly of the well three
days and three nights that uh so will
the son of man be three days and three
nights made a point of like 72 hours and
we know that God is precise and
everything and I try to count back I
used to believe like good Friday and
then Sunday resurrection Easter Sunday
and I tried to and so uh I was reading
and I I forget what gospel but there was
a special Sabbath of that year was
called the high Sabbath and that uh was
Nissan according to the calendar was
Nissan I believe the 15th. So if Jesus
was resurrected on on I believe late on
the Sabbath if you count back 72 hours
it had to be before sundown on
Wednesday. All right because the high
Let me jump in William if you don't
mind. Okay. You're you're basing you're
basing your study there in my opinion on
the verse that Jesus uh where he says in
Matthew 12 as Jonah was in the belly of
the great fish three days and three
nights so the son of man will be in the
heart of the earth. He never says the
son of man will be in the tomb. Some
people have mistakenly believed that
meant that he would be in the tomb.
Christ is talking about the period of
time that he would be in the Greek is uh
the cardia that's the heart of the world
for three days and three nights Jesus
was bearing the sin of the world it
started on Thursday night at the last
supper when he was betrayed Jesus said
now is the hour of darkness that's when
it starts he even says now is the hour
three times I think and then Thursday
night Friday night and s uh Sabbath
Saturday night Christ was suffering for
the sins of the world, the punishment
and the death for our sins. And it had
nothing to do with being in the tomb.
When when we pray the Lord's prayer and
say, "Thy will be done in earth." We
don't mean in the tomb. It talks about
in the world as it is in heaven. So,
Satan came Thursday night. God withdrew
his power after Jesus said the third
time, "Not my will, thy will be done."
He began to suffer for the sins of the
world. Thursday night, Friday night,
Saturday night, three days, three
nights, you're correct. God is precise,
but it it's just understanding what does
the heart of the earth mean. It's only
one verse in the Bible. You don't need
to move the crucifixion and resurrection
to try to accommodate the tomb because
that's not what that verse means. Now, I
got to go to another call, but I'll send
you a book on this, William, and I'm
glad that you've been listening. It's
called The Sign of Jonah. And there it
talks about those three days and three
nights. The sign of Jonah. Call
8008356747.
We'll send you a free copy. and we thank
you for your call. With that, we're
going to keep moving. Going to talk next
to Lois, who's calling from Victorville,
California. You there, Lois? I'm here.
Hey, thank you for calling in and your
question. Oh, the bachelor. My question
is I have a niece and her name is
Shakina.
And you know, I often when I'm studying,
I know of Shikina glory
in the temple. And I'm my question is,
is that okay for a human just to have
the name Shikina? Well, you know, you've
probably met people before that have the
name Jesus.
Yes. I know that must be tough on a kid
because uh it's not as common in some
countries, but in some Latin American
countries, I've met several friends and
their names were Jesus, which is Jesus.
Yeah. Yeah. And you know, I I would
think of all the names that would be a
tough name. I forget what uh recently
there was there was a court ruling some
parents I think that they were in New
York somewhere. They they named their
kid Adolf Hitler and uh the court
actually said you can't do that because
it's too cruel to do that to a kid. And
they had a big court case out of that.
But as far as Shikina, I don't think
there's anything wrong. There there are
people in the Bible like Elijah, his
name means my God is Jehovah. Uh a
number of the Bible characters had go
had uh names that incorporated the name
of God in their names. Daniel means God
is my judge. Um when matter of fact,
whenever you find the word L in a name,
Michael, who is as God, that's what
Michael means, who is like God. Whenever
you find L, it's a derivative of Elohim.
And so I wouldn't uh I wouldn't worry
about having your you say daughter or
granddaughter named Shikina. It's a
beautiful name and it just means glory.
You know, you've met people named Grace
and you've met people named hope and her
name is glory, the glory of God, a
divine glory. So it's a beautiful name.
Okay. I appreciate your input. Thank you
so much. I'll also be happy to send you
that book we've mentioned uh three times
tonight. A lot of questions about names
tonight. It's called The Name of God and
it says quite a bit about names there.
You'll enjoy it. I wrote it and I
enjoyed writing it. It's called The Name
of God. Call 8008356747.
And by the way, any of the people out
there that would like to read that book,
you can also download it for free at the
AmazingFacts website. Just go to
amazingfacts.org.
I appreciate your call and we're going
to talk next to Frank who's calling from
the Netherlands. Thank you, Frank, for
your phone call.
Yes. Uh glad to be here. Uh it's an
honor talking to you, pastor. But now
it's late in it's late at night there.
It's uh like 4:00. Yeah, very early in
the morning, actually. Well, thank you
for calling, Frank.
Well, uh there was a reason for me
staying up. Um I was kind of afraid I
had well in the past there were some
well when I get fil got filled with the
spirit um I don't know how to explain it
but it felt like something went wrong
then you know and uh like I wasn't
completely filled with spirit so when I
and the next day I felt like I didn't
want to sin but I still wanted to sin
and uh and it when it got further I've
had some
accidents with sexual relationships and
some secret vice again but now I'm
afraid and drugs but now I'm afraid have
I have I commit the unpardonable sin.
Well, I think the fact that you're
calling and that you're interested in uh
doing the will of God, it would be the
Holy Spirit that would even convict you
to want to renew your relationship.
Um yeah, don't be discouraged if even
after you come to God, you feel the tug
of the world. Paul talks there in Romans
chapter 7 about, you know, that there's
this war that goes on before complete
surrender where you have a desire to do
God's will, but there's also a desire
for the flesh and the carnal things
because, you know, we do have bodies
that are uh, you know, have animal
passions and we have a spiritual mind
and we try to balance these things as a
Christian. So, uh, don't be discouraged
and just, you know, just pray and come
to the Lord and say, 'Lord, I I I just
would like some encouragement from the
Holy Spirit. I I, um, by the way, before
I even forget, I wrote a book about what
is the unpardonable sin and I'll send
you a free copy of that. It's called,
you know, about the book Beyond Mercy.
I've already ordered it. Oh, good. Good.
So, you haven't read it yet? Yeah.
you'll enjoy that and that will I think
encourage you. Uh I've a lot of people
call and they they worry, have we
grieved away the Holy Spirit? When you
grieve away the Holy Spirit, you're
doing what Judas did where you're just
continually rebelling against God.
You're doing what Balam did. You're
doing what Saul, King Saul did. King
Saul just kept Yes. And my question was
about Saul. Saul uh Saul after he
grieved the the Lord said uh the uh my
spirit has departed from him and then
then Saul still asked for uh the
forgiveness it seemed with David
when uh when he asked to play the harp
and stuff in
I don't think King Saul had completely
grieved way the Holy Spirit at the time
that David was anointed. I do think that
the Holy Spirit um there was a battle
going on because when David would play
his harp, Saul would feel better and he
would be inspired and then at other
times he'd start to brood and it's like
he was wrestling with demonic
possession. But Jesus healed many people
from demon possession and they were
saved. And so just because a person has
um grieved the spirit doesn't always
mean they've permanently grieved away
the spirit.
I think whenever we sin, we all grieve
So, I would I would tell you, don't be
discouraged. You know what? I'm not
saying don't be convicted by sin. I'm
saying don't be discouraged and think
I've committed the unpardonable sin and
throw your hands in the air. Um, seek
after God. You know, as long as you feel
that the Holy Spirit is bringing
conviction and talking to your heart,
feed your soul. Pray. It is true. Even
as Mary and Joseph when they brought
Jesus to the temple, they lost track of
him for a few days and they spent time
sorrowing looking for him. Sometimes we
lose track of Jesus and it takes some
time praying and sorrowing to find him
again. So, but don't get discouraged. I
believe that the Holy Spirit's still in
your life. Read that book. I think
you'll find a number of scriptures to
encourage you, Frank. And thank you for
calling from the Netherlands. Just again
proof that we do have people around the
world calling. talking next to Adam
who's calling from is it Brownssworth,
Texas.
Yes, sir. That's correct, Pastor Doug.
And well, thank you for calling.
Thank you for taking my call. Uh I just
got a quick little observation. I've uh
I've been uh been
the Holy Spirit's been working with me
since I was 5 years old and uh I'm
fixing to be uh 51. So uh it's been a
while. I told a lie. I actually got
saved when I was 13. So anyway, uh I
really got in the Bible real started
reading it uh you know myself verse by
verse and still have it read to me or
preached to me uh by the way of TV or
evangelist, right? But anyhow, I was
going back to Genesis there at uh the
curses uh Revelation, I mean Genesis
3:16. Mhm. And it says uh you know
because I've I was at a young age when
my wife I mean and it says I'll multiply
your sorrow in conception
and in pain you shall bring forth
children. Well, as soon as uh you know
started reading that, it hit me. You
know, well, you know what? I remember my
wife asking all kinds of questions about
childhood till she had one. Mhm. That'd
be a moot statement if she'd never had
children before. Yeah. How would how
would you have something to relay that
to? You know what I mean? I mean,
obviously she Now, in heaven, there's
going to be no pain in heaven. And pain
was not part of God's original plan. And
it it is curious but um
I don't think I think before Adam and
Eve sin child birth was
the prison plan chase down his prodical
son's Lucifer and teach you teach him a
lesson because he's I mean you know all
that I mean that's what I want. So was
your question Adam was your question
about women having pain in conception
and child birth? I was just stating the
fact that uh uh he was cursing or
something. I mean, you wouldn't if he
was grounding your children and saying
you're grounded uh uh you can't play
with your PlayStation for a week and
daddy he had bought me a PlayStation
yet. What I'm saying is is I mean when I
read that to a woman and and think about
it for a second, it it tones on him that
he would have made that statement to her
unless she'd been given birth, right?
No, I I disagree. I see. God had told
Adam and Eve right after they were
created, "Be fruitful and multiply
before sin." He wanted them to be
fruitful. He made them to procreate and
fill the earth. Uh it probably was not
going to be painful to have children
prior to sin. And how God was going to
work that out, I don't know. It seems
like there are some creatures in the
animal kingdom that uh they give birth
and it doesn't look like they go through
the agony that a woman does, a human.
So, uh, hey, I appreciate your call and,
uh, thank you very much, Adam. With that
though, we're going to move along, talk
to Warren, who's calling from
Huntsville, Alabama. Warren, you're on
the air with Bible Answers Live. Well,
hello, Pastor Doug. Thank you for taking
my call. Yes. My question,
uh, an extreme mental ill person, will
they be lost or slaved?
Well, if a person is struggling with,
you know, a a physical mental uh or a
biological mental illness, um the Lord
is going to probably look upon them as
though a child who has not reached the
age of accountability. I think we've all
seen full-grown adults that for some
reason are mentally handicapped and
they, you know, they've got the
emotional ability of a child or less.
God is not going to judge them where you
know they don't have the faculties to
reason between right and wrong. The
reason the children are not judged until
they reach the age of accountability is
because you know they don't have the the
uh uh maturity of judgment to really
understand the consequences of their
decisions. You know and I think if some
adults understood the eternal
consequences of their decisions we'd be
more careful. But, you know, my
understanding is that he's going to
judge them with great mercy as if they
were children. And there'll be a lot of
people, I think, in heaven that struggle
with some uh mental handicaps in this
life. Now, some people have mental
handicaps because of drug abuse and sin.
And, you know, that's a different story.
Uh some have are handicapped because of
demonic possession because they've given
themselves over by bad behavior. That's
another story. But people who are born
with these handicaps that never mature,
I think God's going to be very kind and
merciful to them. Did that make sense,
Warren? Uh, yeah, it makes sense. Hey, I
appreciate your question very much. And
that does open another phone line. So,
if you have a Bible question, give us a
call. 8004637297.
It looks like we still have some lines
open and enough time. 8004637297.
I'm going to go to talk with Nosy who's
calling from Grand Rapids, Michigan.
Nosy, you're on the air with Bible
Answers Live.
Hi, Pastor Doug. Hi.
Um, I have a question on Revelation
chapter 10. Uhhuh. Verse 4.
Would you please explain to me because I
saw the book of the revelation was open
but he looks like the angel tells him to
shut up the book. Can you explain that?
Yeah. It says, "Now when the seven
thunders uttered their voices, I was
about to write, but I heard a voice from
heaven saying to me, seal up the things
which the seven thunders uttered and do
not write them." Well, they're not being
told to seal up uh the book of um
Revelation.
He's just sealing up the what the seven
thunders uttered and you know maybe it
was giving the day and the time of
Christ's coming. So it was just one
message that was sealed. Um okay you
know in the book of Daniel chapter 8 it
talks about um things that are sealed. I
think in Daniel 8:26 it says but seal up
the vision for it refers to many days
from now. And you can read in Daniel
12:4 but you Daniel shut the words and
seal the book until the time of the end.
And then again in Revelation 22:10, he
said to me, "Do not seal up the words of
the prophecy of this book, for the time
is near." So whatever was sealed there
in Daniel is unsealed in Revelation. And
we're living in the time of the
fulfillment of that. But there was
something heavenly that these seven
thunders said that was a mystery. Paul
said he was caught up to the third
heaven. He heard things that you can't
even utter. And so, you know, God says
that there's eye hasn't seen, ear has
not heard, neither has it entered into
the heart of man, the things that God
has prepared for those that love him.
So, there's some things we can't even
imagine. Yeah. I appreciate your call,
Nosy, and thank you very much for your
question. I hope that helps a little
bit. All right, with that, we're going
to talk to Ivonne calling from Canada.
Ivonne, you're on the air with Bible
Answers Live. Oh, hi, Pastor Dan.
Evening. Good evening. I am I like to
ask a question pertaining to when God
says he was talking to someone, let's
make man in our own image and likeness.
Mhm. And in John, first John, it says
the word was with God and the word was
God. And I want to think that it's it
was Jesus God was talking to. Yeah.
Well, you know, God, the word used for
God there is Elohim. It is a plural
word. Yeah. God often says, "Let us go
down and see what the man has done." In
Genesis 11, that's God the Father, Son,
and the Holy Spirit. Right? That's why
the angel says, "Holy, holy, holy is the
uh is the Lord because you've got God
the Father, you've got God the Son, and
God the Holy Spirit." And um that's God
was no doubt talking to Jesus. You know,
Ivon, we're going to try and get one
more call on the air. If you do have um
uh uh further questions on that subject,
all you need to do is go to Amazing
Facts. We'll send you a book on the
Trinity and it'll talk more about that.
We're going to talk last call. Sherry
from Medford, Oregon. Sherry, we just
squeezed you in. You have a quick
question. Uh hi, Pastor Doug. Can you
hear me? I can. My My question pertains
to forgiving people. I I I people
there's been a number of people who bore
false witness against me in a formal
hearing that was under oath and I've
tried to forgive them and I don't dwell
on it but occasionally it comes back to
mind and I think that sure was a you
know an awful thing to do again I don't
wish him ill tried to forgive him but
those thoughts come back what should I
do that's a great question and you know
it's very relevant I know it's very
painful when something like that happens
and and you hear people say terrible
things that are not true about you. Uh,
and that's when it really becomes hard
to forgive, but that's when it really is
important. Jesus was willing to forgive
those who bore false witness against
him. The last thing Steven said before
he died and when they were about to
stone him, he said, "Lord, lay not this
sin to their charge." And here Saul,
later known as Paul the Apostle, had
borne false witness against Steven. And
Steven lost his life because of it. But
Steven was willing to forgive. He said,
"Lord, don't charge him with this sin."
So sinful people will do selfish things.
Sin makes people mentally ill. So you
just got to forgive people that are
cruel as though they got a mental
illness and they can't help it. And just
say, "Lord, help them. Give them a new
heart and transform them." Thank you,
Jerry, for your question. I appreciate
your call. And I do have a a message on
forgiveness at the Amazing Facts
website, amazingfacts.org.
And I trust that you'll find some more
answers there. listening friend, you can
tell that we're starting to run low on
time. Do have some important
announcements following our broadcast
time tonight, but I want to make sure
that you do know that there are more
resources available at the Amazing Facts
website. We'd love to hear from you.
Make a donation and keep us on the air.
God bless till next week.
Thank you for listening to today's
broadcast. We hope you understand your
Bible even better than before. Bible
Answers Live is produced by Amazing
Facts, a faith-based ministry located in
Sacramento, California.
Deep within the pages of the Bible,
stories of great heroes,
heroes of great deeds,
great love,
and great sacrifice.
But behind them is another hero, hidden
in plain sight amid the shadows.
He was there from the beginning,
and he'll be there until the end.
Discover the golden thread of a Savior
woven throughout the entire Bible
tapestry.
Shadows of Light.
Seeing Jesus in all the Bible, a new
book by Doug Bachelor.
Get your copy today by calling
8005387275
or visit afbookstore.com.
Once again, to purchase your copy of
Shadows of Light, call 8005387275.
In 6 days, God created the heavens and
the earth. For thousands of years, man
has worshiped God on the seventh day of
the week. Now each week, millions of
people worship on the first day. What
happened? Why did God create a day of
rest? Does it really matter what day we
worship? Who is behind this great shift?
Discover the truth behind God's law and
how it was changed. Visit
sabathtruth.com.
[Music]
If you'd like to enhance your study of
God's word, visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.org.
o rg and sign up for our free Bible
study course. And make sure to check out
our online bookstore at afbookstore.com,
which offers thousands of inspiring
books, DVDs, and more to help you get
the most out of God's word. To take
advantage of the offers you've heard on
this broadcast, call us at 8008356747
or visit our website at
amazingfacts.org.
Did you enjoy this program? Make sure to
tell your family and friends. Tune in
next time for more Bible Answers Live.
Honest and accurate answers to your
Bible questions.
[Music]